in the mid twenties i had uh this this
semi ironic comic book collection
uh
doing it as a bit
mm-hmm do it like like so much of my
life i was doing it as a bit um i was
enjoying it
we do what was the last movie that you
saw in theaters before the pandemic
cats that's right so uh this was very
much my uh
i had like three long boxes of going to
see cats in theaters
[Laughter]
we are going to talk about moon night
today we're going to talk about what
fans want to see in the moon night
television series that is coming to
disney plus at some point
in the not too distant future starring
oscar isaac as moon knight and ethan
hawk as i don't know sun
ninja what's the opposite who is
the day man i think
what
why didn't i think of that i feel like a
[ __ ] the fighter of the night man
so tom
i i think out of the three of us you
probably know the most about moon knight
my knowledge of him is based mostly on
collecting marvel cards when i was a kid
and never reading a moon night comic
totally so
i know little bits and pieces from the
internet from working at looper from
being a person who used to be in comic
book stores a lot but other than that
it's pretty blank i know like the the
basics so tom what do you think fans are
looking for in the moon night series
i don't know what fans are looking for
bro i can tell you what i'm looking for
uh
because i i did i got
sort of in the moonlight there for a
little while in the in the mid-20s i had
uh this this semi-ironic comic book
collection
uh
doing it as a bit
mm-hmm do it like like so much of my
life i was doing it as a bit um i was
enjoying it
what was the last movie that you saw in
theaters before the pandemic
cats that's right so uh this was very
much my uh i had like three long boxes
of going to see cats in theaters
[Laughter]
and one of the things that i got really
into was moon night and it was it was
because there was this uh video game
back in the in the mid 2000s uh called
ultimate alliance where you got to make
a team of superheroes and fight
it's exactly like that i don't know
and my brother and i would play it and
we would we would play it with on
purpose just the worst teams that we
could put together so it was it was just
all the worst
characters it was like mr fantastic and
yeah and uh like pre-movie
miss marvel and so characters that just
don't go together at all so mr fantastic
and moon night it was already a pairing
that
does not work exactly yeah uh and and
and that was what got me into the
character was like oh this guy kind of
sucks and then i started reading a bunch
of the comics and frequently he does it
he's he's one of those characters that
like if you get a great writer on board
it's
really terrific stories come out but
like the rest of the time he's sort of a
minefield of bad ideas uh he's you know
got multiple personalities and is he
crazy or is he
the champion of the ancient egyptian
moon god khan shoot like
there's a lot of it's
it's it's like any other comic book
character
the potential for fun is there uh so is
the potential for just really cringy bad
stuff
what i am looking for in in the
moonlight series uh actually it kind of
springs from the eternals movie
and a moment that was that that happened
in there where uh one of the characters
gets asked if he's superman
right
which implies that like dc comics exists
in the mcu
uh what i would really like to see is
for for
mark spector from moonlight to be
explaining his whole deal to somebody
uh going like i i jump through the i
leap from building the building dressed
in a monochromatic uniform
find justice in in the night time
and i fly around in a in an airplane
that's shaped like my favorite thing and
then somebody's like
so like batman and he's like no not like
batman i'm i'm what i'm doing
what i really want is just
a whole episode of him trying to explain
to somebody how he's not ripping off
batman
that's that's my
i throw boomerangs in the shape of my
favorite thing at criminals and i'm
really good at martial arts and i i
don't really have any superpowers
so like batman no not like batman that's
what i want that's what i think the fans
want
that's what you think the fans want you
want
you want moon knight to have an awful
explanation as to why he's not ripping
off batman i just yeah i wanna i wanna
see how hard he can lean into
trying to explain that no this this
isn't this isn't just batman but in
white instead of black
on that same note i'd really like in the
morbius movie at some point someone to
say it's some kind of batman
and then they're like what are you
talking about and then that hard cut to
the next scene yeah that's my personal
fantasy but anyway sorry i've gotten way
off track already we all have uh
nina what about you what do you think
fans want to see what do you want to see
in the moon night tv series
oscar isaac's beautiful face mostly just
that i'm going to watch it for oscar i
think i love oscar isaac i don't know
anything about moon knight sorry
i'm just putting it out there i don't
know anything about moon knight i i did
read our article on looper.com though
and something interested me about moon
knight and it led me to a hollywood
reporter opinion piece from 2019
that kind of talked about the way that
the moon knight comics dealt with mental
illness and mental health because the
character has disassociative personality
disorder but it's like a superpower and
he can choose what his personalities are
is what i gleaned from this which is
super mentally extremely not how that
works right um and so
in recent years uh
we've seen a lot of shows with
throughout wildly different genres
tackle
mental health so you had like bojack
horseman crazy ex-girlfriend you're the
worst three shows that i really love you
have specials like bo burnham's inside
that like you know are very direct about
the struggles of living with a mental
illness or mental health problems but
are like presented in a totally
different format
and i think to my mind the only
superhero thing especially marvel that
has tackled this is jessica jones which
dealt with ptsd like pretty effectively
i'm if i'm missing something tell me i
might be admit three
iron man three actually yeah completely
sure yeah
yeah yeah shane black he's great but so
yeah i mean
i think we're we're living in an age of
entertainment where people talk about
this stuff more which i think is
ultimately a good thing and so i do
think if this show approaches his
disassociative personality disorder
with
uh just a smarter approach and a sharper
eye and not be like haha you can make
all these identities which is like
off-putting and you know not realistic
and and so yeah and you've got this this
world-class
oscar-nominated oscar-nominated actor do
you get it in the lead role i think so
ethan hawking
okay so his name's oscar oh okay no i do
yeah okay
awesome
so
no i mean ethan hawk and oscar isaac are
no strangers to
great performances and prestige projects
and projects that require a lot of
emotional depth so i guess i'm hoping
that they can approach
like the very dark side of moon knight
with more nuance and
like make it a better more inclusive
depiction for people watching right
don't play it just for drama don't play
it just for
you know
right the weirdness that can happen when
your superhero has multiple
personalities don't be like which
personality is it which one are you
gonna get who's gonna beat you up it's
like no there's i understand like things
have to be heightened but like this is a
real thing that people deal with and so
how there's got to be a good way to to
strike that balance so that's yeah just
more balanced than what i understand is
featured in the comics
yeah yeah which is to say i think i
think none
but we don't know
we don't know they're a couple
i don't know
there's some really wonderful stories i
uh i i pulled up a couple of them uh
volume eight so it was it was like uh
2016 and 2017 uh they do this
really remarkable artistic kind of
bonker story about uh
uncertainty and
being the unreliable narrator and uh as
far as i know they've never like really
gracefully done a uh
this is what mental illness
is really like if you or somebody you
know is strong please call the following
number yeah but yeah all right yeah
he is i mean at his core he is still a
guy who punches people
recreationally
he's
he's not necessarily a
great i don't know icon for mental
stability i mean
i'm not making any comments about this
specifically but there were criticisms
level leveled against joker for maybe
conflating violence and mental illness
in a way that was
unsettling to some people hopefully moon
knight can not do that yeah we want them
to thread the needle effectively but
yeah no i think i think that that's
that's perfectly perfectly reasonable to
to to hope for because you know the the
trailer that we saw we're recording this
not too long after disney plus day even
though this will probably look dark
it definitely looks dark and oscar isaac
is doing something interesting which is
a very
uh exaggerated english accent now as far
as i know mark spector is not an english
character
so my guess is that that accent is one
of these
personalities that are inside his head
these these personas that are going to
come through and so i'm curious to see
how that is going to
kind of bear out once we actually get to
see the
the the show
so
if i'm you know my guess is that you
know if if i'm correct that that is
going to be part of that explanation
they're not going to shy away from it i
hope that what they do doesn't i hope
that what they do doesn't suck i mean
that's pretty obvious i think i think we
all think that nobody wants to see a
sucky show i mean unless it sucks a lot
then i definitely want to see it fans of
moon knight don't want the show to suck
i think that you've made a brave story
fans of moon night
preferred here guys we're done for the
let's get we
day
before we go uh one of the items here on
on the article on looper.com which i'm
very grateful to have in front of me
because as i've mentioned i don't know
this character uh acknowledgement that
moon knight is is jewish now i'm a
jewish person and i am always you know i
have that
that brain problem where any time i see
a a famous jewish person doing something
cool i'm always like oh that guy's
jewish you know and it's like you know
that's
trained into me as a child where you
know
whenever whenever someone someone
hilarious or amazing does something on
tv my dad or mom would always be like
you know that guy's jewish i'd be like
oh that's interesting so it's just you
know my brain goes there first so
knowing that i want moon knight to be
you know if moon knight is going to be
jewish on the show like let's
let's let's play into that there's no
other characters in the mcu that i know
of that have
um that are of the
jewish faith or jewish ethnic background
or anything like that and it's clearly
part of his origin story back in 1984 we
find out that he's the son of a rabbi so
it's kind of one of those things that if
you're going to be at all true to the
character's backstory you have to
include it and one of the reasons why
i'm kind of excited by this prospect is
because
the first time i ever saw oscar isaac on
screen was in the movie ex machina
and for
the whole movie until i looked it up
late until i saw the credits roll i was
like david cromoltz looks great
david cremoltz
really got it she did wow
i was throw a beard
and then i was like oh that's a
different man
imagine and now i'm imagining when i saw
inside lou and davis and being like wow
david crumles can sing
yeah guitar
a lot of people make this mistake a lot
of people think that
i did the same thing it was uh the santa
claus i was like man that oscar isaac is
a small jewish boy
he's a small jewish christmas elf
why is that small jewish boy i made the
same mistake in 10 things i hate about
you
why is he a high school student
why is oscar isaac gone back in time to
be in this movie
um part of the problem is that we're all
insane sorry
um
my point though is that i mean oscar
isaac is not jewish he's he's
and and that's you know obviously it's
not ideal you want representation you
want people who are the thing that
they're playing to be the thing but i
mean obviously you can't always do that
it's okay
um you know in certain contexts in
certain situations so if he's going to
play a jewish person i at least feel
somewhat gratified that he looks
and has been mistaken for
a very jewish actor you know so it's not
out of the realm of possibility that he
could make it work is all i'm trying to
say like if you can get uh what's her
name who who uh
felicity jones is that her name who
played ruth bader ginsburg
please don't get me started on that
i'm just saying there was only one girl
from new york who could
not not one no apparently and you know
what yeah by silverman no we don't talk
about him anymore but you know marty
ginsberg did not look like army hammer
i'm just saying
[Laughter]
no offense r.i.p marty
you know my husband marty ginsberg
didn't look he likes eating people
anyway um
so yeah i think uh
[Music]
i mean that's moonlight right sorry mom
i'm sorry i'm making jokes about the
ginsburgs
this is a good one right i don't know
was this a good one thanks for watching
please hit like and subscribe and if you
watch this far please hit something and
leave a comment to tell us that you did
because i don't believe that anyone's
looking at me right now
[Music]